The correct answers, at least according to me
are: sending proper user-agents, very important, writing custom protocols,
no, you know, there is a time and a
place for it, generally using common protocols and data
formats is a better idea, using soap. [LAUGH] Depending
on whether we mean the protocol or the cleaning
substance. The correct answer may be yes or no.
We're going to go with the protocol, and say,
I wouldn't use it if I could avoid it. You might make, you might make somebody
at Hipmunk really upset. Or rate-limiting yourself, that
is also correct. You know, always be kind,
proper user agents, rate-limit yourself, use protocols and
data formats that everybody knows how to work
with that are easy to work with. Your
life and everybody else's online will be much easier.